western high school
our officers responded to the east
parking lot at dismissal time as
students were actively leaving the
school and getting on school buses
a car was observed at a high rate of
speed entering the parking lot our
officers ordered that vehicle to stop it
continued south through the parking lot
did a u-turn headed back north in the
parking lot at a high rate of speed the
vehicle struck a student we're happy to
say is not injured seriously
and then continued at a high rate of
speed towards our officers our officers
gave orders for the vehicle to stop one
of the officers pulled his service
weapon fired rounds at the car which
then continued
towards him made a right turn and then
exited the parking lot
sometime later two juveniles
were taken by their family members one
to umc and one to sunrise hospital for
non-life-threatening injuries but again
they're being treated right now so i
don't have any information as the extent
of their injuries clark county school
district police department was aided by
the university police department which
are also here at the western property as
well as officers from the las vegas
metropolitan police department
las vegas metropolitan police department
fit team is
conducting the investigation into this
officer-involved shooting in 72 hours
they will brief our command staff and
our investigators as to their findings
and then we will set up in time to do a
further briefing for all media which
will possibly be monday
okay are these juveniles uh students at
western high school uh no they are not
possibly one was assigned to western
high school the others were not and the
two people uh that were sent to the i
think leave umc hospital are they the
individuals in the in the car that was
being uh chased by ccsdpd yes so it was
being attempted our officers were
attempting to stop
were the weapons discharged
it was in the parking lot on the campus
any injuries resulting directly from the
officers no none of our officers were
injured uh during this this encounter
and and no no one was hit by the the
service the rounds that were shot by
there uh it appears that the two uh
person two persons that were in the
vehicle were struck by gunfire
do you know their condition
no we do not we just know that they're
being treated at those two different
hospitals
uh it appears uh that she was hit as the
car was fleeing through the parking lot
not an intended target but you know
officers were yelling for the students
that were in the parking lot to get out
of the way get out of the way and one of
the unfortunately a student was struck
the
the people that were hospitalized they
were the suspect juveniles they were the
vehicles yes they were in the car yes
that struck the student was the student
that was hit by the car were they
hospitalized at all i do not believe so
it it seem like those struck uh and
those driving the car knew each other at
all we don't know that
all right folks thank you very much
thank you all right like i said 72 hours
we'll have our briefing for metro and
then we'll send out a release to
everyone as far as we'll release further
information thank thank you